45 seconds of logos okay
here we go focus speed I am speed movie
that goes back to the first film's
opening because it doesn't have anything
original to say also narration one
winner forty two losers this is the same
opening as the first movie - the show
crow that is for each area of this film
that used unreleased posthumous audio
for this character each of Paul Newman
salad dressings receives one cents
putting your movie title on a Jumbotron
is cute but kiss-cam still plays better
with crowds of all sports wow I realized
that it's pointless to start arguing yet
again how the hell works in this world
of talking cars if one car pulls in
between two cars like this it's pretty
much gonna come up right I mean this is
their physical body their skin it
essentially and this Chris just
squeezing right in between them probably
doing damage to the equivalent of major
organs just so he can watch a race
pretty sure cars for was going to be
about how cow has had enough that
becomes a serial killer hey Bobby
he's a next-generation race car
inexplicably voiced by Armie Hammer
better than you in every way but somehow
he was built added to the circuit and
enrolled in this race without you ever
hearing about him or the media even
knowing he existed until now who is this
mysterious newcomer Jackson Starr and
why is he so mysterious given his
existence represents a massive leap
forward in racing technology also naming
lightnings main antagonist storm is just
the amount of lazy I expect from Disney
these days
Jackson's storm is part of the next
generation of high-tech racers unlike
the veterans of yesterday know what
old-timers like this guy cars three get
off my lawn
storm achieves his top speeds by
exploiting the numbers I refer of course
to racing data Moneyball we've got six
or next generation rookies in the field
this is as good a time as any for me to
once again ask where these fucking cars
come from factories are they fitted with
personalities in a factory did two
former race cars have sex and create a
more advanced race car they're treated
like individual people but this whole
next-gen nonsense suggests that they're
just machines being created by some
big-ass god car in the sky
whether he's hanging up his lightyears
no no comment on that either good a
bunch of the Pixar creative staff get
together and decide that doing a movie
about retirement and getting older was
what the kids today wanted to see there
was more life and up which is a movie
that has an old retired guy as the lead
character thankfully when doc died it
was discovered his will specified that
any of the town's folk could enter his
garage and watch his old racing films
for inspiration your history movie pans
out its run time which is already too
long with archival footage of the Paul
Newman character just waiting for a CGI
grand moff tarkin to pop up randomly
again why because I'm sad and in Doc's
garage staring at old doc racing news
clippings you can either take it or you
can do what you've been doing sitting
aren't they always in the same position
so couldn't you argue that they're
always sitting because problem with the
Cars universe is that the dialogue is
full of humanistic expressions that
don't fit into the parameters of their
universe I get that after the reception
of the second Cars movie the creators
wisely realize that less mater is better
however couldn't they have tried no
mater I'm gonna be faster than storm I
need to train like them now you need to
be rebuilt to have 2% lower drag
coefficient and 1.2 percent higher top
speed he's literally better than you in
every way and you already use that turn
right to go left thing in the first
movie so you cannot win it's impossible
that's Primus
[Applause]
[Music]
instead of life as a highway by Rascal
Flatts this movies driving montage gives
us this Knoxville
really you couldn't just drive through
regular old real last Knoxville on your
way from Colorado to Florida this is the
most unnecessary fictional name since
mr. Tonka penis Luigi and Guido might be
the most culturally insensitive set of
autonomous robots since skids and
mudflap things we previously could not
track apparently I have the next gen
plastic wrap pink job if you want to
track a resource pede does it have a
phone I mean but they do write basically
every Tio's to their pit crew and
dismiss phone just because it doesn't
literally cover all the cars audio
capabilities multi million how much good
Rusty's have been worth you can use
anything negative as fuel to push
through to the positive blog like the
flu chronic psoriasis or feline AIDS
[Music]
character insists he's not going to do
something only to do said something in
the next scene cliche no it should not
this is the first movie all over again
someone's trying to help him but
lightning it's too stubborn to realize
it and accept that help I feel like
every time someone at Pixar brought this
up during pre-production they were
shouted down by a suddenly operating
group of Disney accountants singing a
barbershop version of Pink Floyd's money
did she say barrier shark you have so
the simulator has a response setup if
you crash into it how was it even still
functioning you are about to become the
biggest brand in racing we are talking
saturation on all continents for every
demographic movie deals infomercials
product endorsements nice at Pixar to
include a scene that pretty much sums up
the only reason cars 3 was made get your
tires dirty that's how you're gonna get
faster than stories
[Music]
I don't ask a lot from my sentient
automobile cartoons but I do ask them to
stay away from terrible dialogue and
sacred dirt usually I get my wish your
brittle like a fossil he is a machine
just fix and/or upgrade him well life's
a beach and then you drive
oh okay cars three recycles the wall-e
joke about the Apple boot-up noise that
was only kind of cute in wall-e hey boys
my speed can he not see the speedometer
because his eyes are in front of the
dash in the windshield can't really
think of a reason why a car sentient or
not would ever need to ask this question
to someone else is this movie about
training crews or McQueen wait I just
realize how this movie's gonna end
also cars 3 is competing with rocky 4
for being over 60% montages
[Music]
well I'm no racing expert and much has
been made about the power of dirt on the
tires but maybe you should speed check
yourself on asphalt instead of sand
surface does make a difference you know
might be the first ever instance of the
street sign X not gonna sin that's what
I need to race against actual racers you
need 10 to 15 more miles per hour speed
you are not going to get it through
motivation I mean you probably will
eventually because this movie hates me
but you should not get it through
motivation this entire movie is
happening when they could have just
given him a new engine or something nos
[Music]
unless it rains or the mud flies off
while he's racing but semantics yep
Lightning entered a small crazy eight
track race without knowing it because
this movie has you by the balls also no
way and he can test his top speed on
this track FYI so basically he entered a
race and vigilante 8 I wonder how many
audience members shared the same
sentiment 10 minutes into this movie
goddamn shit bitch yet I'd like to ask
our editors Brad and Chris totally
different Chris by the way to find a
transparent PNG of a middle finger being
flipped and add it to the next couple
seconds of the movie footage while also
animating it with keyframes to slide
back and forth across the screen like a
windshield wiper okay
that's the I'm talking about them right
off the bat the school bus and RV
keeping up with lightning is bull I'm
glad this extended and utterly useless
country track Racine found time for yet
another callback to the first movie okay
it's not rain but I'm still right also
other than wait why would a former water
truck have water in its tank school bus
doesn't have kids in it the RV doesn't
have Robin Williams in it this should
actually be against the rules whatever
we need lightning to be exposed so what
shall be usually every mile of this trip
was to get me faster than Jackson's
storm I can't get any faster because I'm
too busy taking care of my trainer but
you chose all the destinations bro from
the beach to the country dirt track race
bitch now Cruz is just more selfish
behavior will just become the norm for
you god Lightning McQueen may be the
biggest dick of a protagonist in the
history of film ever because of you
because of him
really he's a selfish dickhead he won a
lot sure but this is like wanting to
become an NFL player because of Tom
Brady I used to watch you on TV flying
through the air was he on pole vaulting
with the car stars why would he be
flying through the air during a car race
being small crews that's what my family
used to say dream small or not at all
Cruz's family is a dicta Cruz I just
left it was my one shot and I didn't
take it well something tells me this bag
of cliches movie will give you that
chance to race you thought was gone
forever
lightning needs ten to 15 more miles per
hour to win this race so naturally he
calls mater for moral support
that's just it mater I don't know I feel
like I'm all out of ideas Pixar's new
slogan what I don't know
pretty sure an early screenplay a
meeting interaction just made it into
the script I'm sorry
some people actually like this movie hey
Cruz you want to check out the home
track of the greatest racer ever why not
we've got 40 more minutes to kill
somehow ok this animation right here
amazing I'm taking a sin off for a movie
I didn't enjoy because I'm all amazing
this is lightning slams on the brakes
here instead of just steering his car to
either side of this truck on the track
apparently these older cars just like to
sit around and a bar and listen to songs
about how old they are cars 3 might be
the saddest animated movie since Bambi
oh that's too short to take no for an
answer I'm sure this is the best message
for kids without some context everything
changed when the rookies showed up how
about that doc had the exact same thing
happened during his career that is
happening now - lightning what sweet
symmetry wonder if he did a sweet racing
move that lightning or someone coming
close will copy later in the final race
racing wasn't the best part of the
Hood's life you were Jesus they got on
the same page at the end of the first
movie
everyone in the world forgets the book
that is the second movie now suddenly
they had a father-son relationship off
screen between movies and lightning was
unaware of how happy this made doc until
he saw a newspaper clippings you'll
never be as fast as storm
finally someone says it but you can be
smarter than him what he literally takes
the optimum path on every lap and his
faster than all cars to sin to sin the
fact that he around this whole time and
miss qualifying the fact that this movie
feels he needs more obstacles to winning
than just a rookie car that literally
goes faster than him
a little really nothing he's done this
entire week has actually done anything
to benefit his desire to beat a much
faster car
this tractor version of house simba
killed his father is supposedly teaching
something to lightning supposedly yeah
that's when you were fast now you're
slow but couldn't they just add parts to
McQueen to make him faster I had to
repair him after the crash so why would
adding a better engine or something
along those lines be such a stretch no
lights
lights and instinct are not opposites
instinct discrete but even Sherlock
Holmes stubs his toe on something in
total darkness yeah yeah there's a Bruce
Almighty moon in the sky but this is
still some total crap also how is this
supposed to help this McQueen going to
be blindfolded in the next race does he
have to take down the Death Star because
his eyes can deceive him et called it's
not flattered Mac shares the sentiment
of anyone who watches this movie
Lightning has a crisis of confidence
right before the big race there are only
two ways this movie ends he regains
confidence touch that wall flip Trickett
docks and wins or he loses but finds
peace and retirement and starts training
Jackson's storm there may be cruise my
money is on the last one but either will
feel cheap but how is he catching up
with all these other cars they are the
same variety and build a storm then
wouldn't they be as fast as him got that
spoiler and those racing tires you look
ridiculous you are a trainer remember ok
now 100% certain lightning will accept
retirement and train crews thanks for
tipping your hand buoy they're not gonna
let you just replace yourself with your
trainer mid-race dude I mean wait the
Argo let him do that you're gonna finish
what so everyone wants to see McQueen
get his one last shot of glory but we're
now gonna have to watch cruise I don't
recall the rocky movie where after three
rounds rocky put his gloves on Paulie
and said go get him questions that could
be asked after the race do these cars
even understand the concept of a time
crunch also what makes cruises car type
able to compete with these new models
she looks like she's in the same class
as McQueen so how does she end up
winning this race especially when she's
so behind or or just put a headset on
McQueen since he's her trainer now and
yes they're gonna do that but only after
three of these tell her this moment's
cruise follows a psychological cliche of
picturing everyone is naked tractors to
get over her anxieties so she can win
the race movie has already shown her
passing more cars than her even in this
race
god damn it was this contractual and if
it was Pixar why did you agree to that
stipulation intentionally ramming
another car into the wall for our half
turn at the track should be illegal as
this is not bumping this is attempted
murder
here's that dock wall flip moon band I
wrote this movie screenplay in my sleep
as you know we have a long history of
great racers set for cow movie felt like
it had time for one more dig at cow
[Music]
smokey knew they were about to add
lightning to the winner's list before
the Jumbotron changed
he's fucking psychic you're the star of
the movie maybe you did some mediocre
racing earlier today does it really
matter
he decides when he's done racing that
was the deal oh yeah Sally
Jean was his girlfriend up until this
movie but I guess they had an amicable
breakup and remained friends this movie
treats Sally like any random Radiator
Springs resident for Bonnie Hunt worried
about what Tex is gonna say considering
the Rusty's thanks Dex
well glad that was wrapped up so neatly
now on the cars for were the Revenge of
cow
[Music]
tell me Jesus
Tavi Jewish God happy Allah
wait a minute Scully what's the point of
this test no point I just thought he
could stand to lose a little weight
yeah I do they're really important in
this pose that you arch your back and
keep it flat at the same time I feel
like those are opposing ideas
merchandising merchandising
merchandising so you're telling me
there's a chance we should mate